stars throw their support for glad
spirit day and we've got how to get away
with murder star Conrad Rick amaura in
the house hey friends today we are
celebrating glad spirit day so of course
we all took the pledge to go purple to
stand against bullying and a stand with
LGBTQ youth because I used to be one in
all sincerity we need spirit day now
more than ever and Hollywood is also
throwing their support including Britney
Spears Ellen and yes RuPaul's Drag Race
I see you Kelly mantle
even HBO and Game of Thrones got in the
spirit with Drew Carey's breathing
purple flames now if you thought that
was dope then prepare yourself because
Queen Celine not only brought the fire
and honor of Spirit Day she let it rain
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh nothing like Queen Celine slaying the
Prince vocals it is a special day indeed
folks and earlier this week how to get
away with murder star and the Filipino
brother Conrad Rico Morris stop by our
set to talk about the significance of
spirit day so much for joining us on a
special day - yeah glad spirit day
spirit day I mean it's such an important
pouring campaign and movement I'm one
out start by asking you what does spirit
day mean to you well I mean growing up
as a gay teenager who was in the closet
in the south it was a really tough
experience and getting bullied and you
know it's we didn't have anything like
or at least I didn't know about it
anything called GLAAD spirit day there
was no support so to have this national
organization that's providing acceptance
and support for LGBTQ people all over
the nation is a really great thing
everyone has a coming-out story I we're
know what was that experience like for
you I was it was the summer after my
sophomore year in college and I told my
best friend Tanya that I needed to tell
her something
and we drove to a park and it took me
probably 30 45 minutes with my head in
my hand and just like oh my gosh but it
took I had an ally I had someone and she
was straight she wasn't a part of the
LGBTQ community but she was a
compassionate human being and that's
what we need more of I just hope that
everybody has somebody like that in
their lives amen to that
I mean what advice do you have for the
the youth out there LGBTQ students in
particular who are maybe struggling with
themselves and who filled like maybe
they're different oh gosh advice just
that I know what you're going through
I've been there I know what it's like to
be scared I also know what it's like to
live in a place where you don't feel
safe to come out and if that's the case
then then I know I'm I feel your pain
and if you do have anybody that is an
ally that you can go to to talk to you
find them talk to them if you see
anybody that's wearing like a purple
on Thursday then you know that you have
somebody that you can trust that you can
talk to and just to hang in there
because you know it does get better and
we'll all be waiting for you when you
make it out absolutely I mean look at us
we it does get better have you been able
to kind of take a step back and realize
the impact that character is made on
people's lives
yeah because I get messages I get I see
all your DMS my Instagram I know my
Twitter and all that stuff so I hear
from you all out there that are letting
me know what it's like to be represented
because I'm multiracial a half Asian
because I'm gay and I'm playing a gay
character and also because I'm playing
an hiv-positive character I hear from
all of those populations with the impact
that it's having but I like that our
show doesn't comment on it it's just
plot stuff that the writers are working
out but they're not using you know you
know the the status or the ethnicity or
the sexuality as like the drama speaking
of the drama I cannot let you leave
without us giving us a little bit of
scoop of tonight's episode what can we
accept sure I mean you're going to learn
more about Conners dad's plural yeah
you're also going to be learning more
about Conners struggle with law school
whether he should stay in or not and you
know Oliver's created this business
you're gonna learn more about his
journey moving forward and you're also
gonna get another piece of the puzzle
for Knight X which is a murder thing my
thanks again to Conrad for stopping by
you guys can catch him on how to get
away with murder Thursday nights on ABC
now before we sign off today is not only
GLAAD Spirit Day but just so happens to
be another momentous occasion the
one-year anniversary of the day I met
Oprah a coincidence that she also
starred and got her start in the color
purple I think not all right here's a
snapshot of our moment together check it
out it's like she's pointing at my soul
and luck she's grabbing on my hand and I
have more receipt but let me set this up
for you guys first
the day I met Oprah began like any other
day I was set on assignment to cover the
LA premiere of boo Ahmadiyya Halloween
and first of all the tip sheet which has
the names and photos of all the stars
expected to walk the carpet had Tyler
Perry a couple stars from the film's
some influencers and like frat boy
number 1 through 8 so basically the
carpet was looking bleak people then all
of a sudden you hear photographers on
the line lose their minds and cameras
are flicking everywhere Rigo who's
shooting this right now he was there you
remember this all of a sudden it was her
it was Oprah and needless to say I was
stunned she is my idol of course and
here's what never made it on et it's
Oprah barreling down the red carpet
trying to leave by the way before
stopping at me for this brief
life-changing moment Oprah how's it fit
abeer support way to sag alright if you
love the film I love that I laughed my
god I literally Gayle and I watched
together and I was literally falling out
of my seat wait for the help me Jesus
seemed help me Jesus Madea or the color
purple Easter egg or the color purple
Easter Egg all my life I had it's good
Oprah grab my hand people Oprah grab my
hand
clearly our time together was cut short
and can I just say a lot has changed in
the year and I on my own show a year
after I met Oprah and a year after she
held my hand coincidence I think not
you know she's also doing pretty good
for herself these days and I think we
need to make this an annual thing this
Winfrey plus I make a mean Moscow Mule
anyway thanks for putting up with me
today and every day you guys I really do
feel lucky that I have this show and
that I'm not only empowered but
encouraged to be myself I don't take
that for granted and I think every
person should be given the freedom to be
exactly who they are so be kind to each
other out there and as always be kind of
yourself alright
Oprah
[Music]